oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys i feel like i haven't
seen you in a while welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast i am thomas
dobasiola this is marty drastic graphics
to my right guys thank you for watching
the topaz usual podcast this is episode
33. we are here to talk about life drugs
accomplishments problems and everything
in between right before we started my
dad called me and says you should make a
sticker with your face it says dope as
usual and then this parentheses it's not
for everybody that's a great idea dad
that's a good like it's definitely not
for everybody i don't think about it
often but you're probably right
no some people would think we're
degenerates yeah we've had some guests
be like
i don't know if i could do your show
we won't say who but we had a couple
dudes go i can't i just can't do it bro
that's that's okay
we'll see you soon
guys it's episode 33. we just got the
consultation new set is being built this
weekend on the other side of this wall
all right it's going to be awesome we
yes we have a really nice office space
on the other side we don't use
because we thought we needed the
warehouse to do a show
but marty and i also have never done
this before building a set like this so
here we go square one guys guys guys hi
hello
what's going on this is the first time
we've ever filmed on a weekend isn't it
i think so hmm i think so
saturday and the day i don't mind i kind
of like it i love the saturday there's
no traffic
yeah um
let's get right into this quick some
quick life updates what's going on marty
is two weeks out from his house being
completely built
allegedly allegedly he's been just
eating sawdust for a couple days
basically literally yeah i facetimed him
and he goes i got sawdust in my eyes and
emery his little daughter locked all the
doors so they were all the doors were
locked out until
we only we can only be in the upstairs
because the downstairs is fully under
construction still so we got like then
she goes and locks all the doors except
the room that we're in this just me and
her for the whole day i got goddamn
sawdust oh it was just you two she did
it on purpose
no no no you're going nowhere no luck
doors no exactly what happened though
shouting at her and showed she had
looked at you i locked all the doors i
was like no what oh god yeah you don't
realize what you did today i was getting
all of my contacts and [ __ ] i was having
issues even driving up here [ __ ] eyes
all bloodshot and [ __ ] all [ __ ] up
red eyes advising
it worked
it's the first time i bought advising in
my life
how is that possible i don't my eyes
don't get ready when i get home
yeah i've never bought advising before
it's like such a like it's a creepy like
style type of thing yeah i don't know i
don't know how it's just this it's like
five bucks
all right i would have bought half a
blunt [ __ ] my eyes being red i mean if i
was in high school still
um
what else knew guys last night what time
is it like two
like 10 hours ago i got my car back
finally uh we finally got the car
wrapped i'll pop up a picture it's not
done yet
but the car is finally wrapped in the
blue i've been looking at for a year
i'm so happy we're almost done guys
shout out to studio motors in burbank
dave you're the man
just got it all done we're we're filming
it for the adventures of yolo channel my
second channel we're filming the entire
car being customized from rims accents
car being wrapped everything is being
filmed
it's going to be sick i got your own
footage god that place is so legit too
just going in there bro check out their
youtube man studio motors on youtube
it's
great if you like car stuff you just
found a new channel for real um
i think that's everything that's going
on in like my current stuff oh no
rosie's right now is getting wedding
dresses that's where she's at with her
mom and her sister
they're looking at all the wedding
dresses at some convention or something
i don't know but she's looking right now
so
planning weddings and tons of fun super
easy and not stressful
sarcasm
if you can't if you're in the car you
don't know marty's being sarcastic
because i thought
you're lying [ __ ]
yeah no uh somebody just sent us a
wedding book and we don't know who sent
it we've called everybody in our
contacts
so shout out to you whoever [ __ ] sent
this [ __ ] so we're planning it all out
i'm not planning it out we're doing the
whole hey let's do it we have time so
that's what's going on right now
guys let me talk about one thing i
probably will never talk about it again
i'm gonna talk about i'm gonna start i'm
gonna lead the way so
marty doesn't get upset over here let me
lead the way and then start it and then
marty you could can you start talking i
don't want you to start [ __ ]
knuckle [ __ ] battery screwdriver
i don't want buffalo marty coming out
you guys ready here we go
i have been doing something called story
time
i'm about to be on season four
90 100 episodes deep
um what 50 million views a little over
50 million
views
on my series just one series has over 50
million views on these episodes i'm
shadow band i'm age restricted
meaning i don't get shown like regular
youtubers you have to type my name in
and scroll and find my page so could you
imagine that 50 million probably being
doubled if i wasn't age restricted in
shadow band so 50 million views while
being [ __ ] on all right
i did not invent story time
at all people have been doing people
tell stories what do you think movies
are
i am no way shape or form saying i
invented story time not at all
nothing but i've been doing story time
in seasons with the same color the same
theme the thumbnails the titles shift
different pictures for each season same
color same theme same
structure dead on every episode right
so we call it story time orange as you
can see
the orange behind me the orange the
orange the room the story time the
entire office orange bathroom
story time orange that's what we called
it so the reason i'm bringing all this
up sorry if you guys like what the [ __ ]
you talking about colors here we go
i do something called story time we have
the biggest cannabis channel
on youtube youtube right for cannabis
we've been doing this stuff for a long
time
i love seth rogen you guys know i love
that [ __ ] i want him on the show
we actually talked to his management
about getting him on the show they said
yes just when he has time so we've been
sitting for a couple months like yo when
is that seth rogen episode coming
because
i want to hear this dumb ass
i want to hear that it's a stupid laugh
and my dumb ass laugh i think it'd be
fun smoking cross joints going here can
you keep up seth rogen hit this bong are
you any like it would just be a really
good episode i'm a fan super fan you
guys know that marty and i both love the
guy i want him on the show
reason i'm bringing this up
and i'm bringing it up because so many
people have been talking about it still
and i
need to address it fully so you know
where we're coming from we're not
[ __ ]
seth rogen just released a podcast
but it's called story time with seth
and the damn colors are orange story
time orange color and it's not like the
whole thumbnail's the same of course not
then it'd be blatant
but it's like their act their their
theme colors like is is my exact orange
which is fine because houseplant does
orange i get that it's not like he's
like oh orange oh story time give me a
weed you're mine
that's what i'm not thinking
but the circumstances talked to the
management they checked our [ __ ] out
said yeah we're gonna come on when he
has time
then they don't have time then they
start their own podcast called story
time with seth rogen and it's orange
and i know some of you guys it's not
that deep it's not that i get that it's
not that it's not that you think joe
seth rogan's going
stealing this guy's stuff no he's a
[ __ ] famous ass rich dude he's not
worrying about some youtuber kid
but i'm not going to say his management
didn't peep our [ __ ] and go what's the
biggest [ __ ] in weed oh this guy doing
stories we can do that and you know what
call it the same [ __ ] thing
because for a while it was called story
time with yola that's what it was called
season one i wanted to ch and i changed
it because you know i dropped it with
you all you guys know who i am that's
what it was called
i changed all the thumbnails all the
[ __ ] back before i met you actually
so i'm looking at it like wait i feel a
little play but it's okay it's just a
color oh i feel a little played it's
just a story title because people say
story time all the time but that's the
name of my series that's the name
it's not like here's a story time it's
story time we have gifs
type dopaziola on any platform and story
time pops up that's our [ __ ] not saying
we invented i'm saying that's like what
we love to do that's what we're known
for is telling stories
and then i'm like wait and you're a
podcast wait and we just asked you to
come on the show and you checked our
[ __ ] out
oh
damn it
i just hope it's not the bad part not
the shitty way of going y'all to steal
this kid [ __ ] i don't think it's that
way i don't know if it is
it's just a lot of similarities
and similarities are fine but if we
didn't just talk to the management about
coming on and they're like yeah sounds
great when he's got time
so we're sitting here waiting for the
show for him to come on the show and
then i'm like wait you started your own
show and called it my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so that's where we're at guys it's it's
more of is it on purpose because it
looks like it is but i'm not going to
hold you to it because i'm not just
going to make assumptions but i have
every right to be concerned and pissed
not piss
feel a little played
that's what i should say
go marty
yeah i mean [ __ ] i just feel i was never
mad at any point i just knew we had to
you got to speak about yourself
on somebody
you weren't mad you just felt like
[ __ ] no yeah that i saw it on your face
there's a lot of things yeah you can't
to me it's like you can't put in all
that sweat and granite there's other
story times on youtube for sure but my
main thing is
he's got to be embarrassed if you're not
embarrassed to come into this same space
on youtube
it's a completely unoriginal theme like
bro you got too much money as a com as
the owner of a business that brands
podcasts even if it is your team that's
still not an excuse yeah because he
might have no [ __ ] of course he has no
idea i'm i'm willing to say he didn't
probably even knows he has a [ __ ]
podcast nope exactly
that team does yes that's where it's
like they may be like well what works on
youtube what's going on story time we're
the top on every star category the
demographics of who the fans are on
youtube it doesn't matter if it's a
podcast or not it's a youtube show
that's all you know and neither of us
was even mad but it's just no we weren't
mad until day two and it went yeah you
gotta pipe up if you don't pipe up for
yourself then what the [ __ ] you what do
you stand for like yeah you can't let
some celebrity come into the space with
all these big you know and we're just
guessing that we haven't even actually
thought about this yet in the past since
i went on instagram about this [ __ ] but
we're just kind of assuming you haven't
he's going to have on all these
celebrities it's going to start really
bumping down all those story time videos
if you start putting out episodes as a
super famous celebrity but
do whatever you want that was the other
thing but address it like do whatever
you want our whole point is you got to
just say like oh bro
totally not we just it's just a
coincidence like
that's all i wanted to hear man that's
all i wanted to hear because i'm tired
of people stealing everything from me
it's happened for forever youtube steals
all my money i don't get paid
2.7 mil all right give it i would love
it youtube but it's okay keep it you
need another boat
um
i just i just can't get played again
yeah it's like if you're gonna come in
here and like try to appeal to all our
fans and just take our [ __ ] because you
know what works you gotta have yellow on
your podcast or you gotta come on ours
and at least address just talk i'm like
bro i would be happy you know how happy
i was but when sick yeah he's gonna tell
stories i'm [ __ ] there and now it's
like wait what's it called because the
reason i found out i had about 50 dms
going what the [ __ ] and i went what
what's wrong with seth rogen what
happens he i was like
no did he do something weird please tell
me he's not a weirdo and then i saw i go
oh man
are you kidding me
i wasn't the [ __ ] chiropractor like
that oh
no i called you immediately no way bro i
was more pissed than you were off the
bat because once i looked and saw it was
the orange and it's just like it's not
just saying like oh it's just a color i
get that of course there's only a title
and a look you can't it's not okay to be
that unaware though if you're a mega
celebrity with infinite money you have
infinite possibilities to brand your own
show
you got to be a little aware because i
get pissed off when it's like all these
celebrities coming into podcasting just
to leech it out of the money they can
they see people get money and podcasting
i'm gonna come in and use my name and
just suck all the money out of
podcasting i can but that waters it down
for the people that are actually in it
going out and trying to get brand
sponsors and deal when you get some
you know like plug and play ass podcast
coming in and then they sit there and
phone in [ __ ] ad reads i've seen it
happen a million times so i mean [ __ ] if
you stop on our toes we're gonna [ __ ]
say something that's it yeah that's all
we're just saying something it's just a
gp address so you're not going damn
these fools didn't say [ __ ] huh just let
them take it
like nah bro that's not the way it
happened
how about this oh i have a smoke off for
it for sure as long as you even came at
them like no i love the guy
it's the management it's the management
team going
they had to have looked and if you
didn't then that's just as bad yeah if
you didn't though at least tell us like
bro i swear to god
we didn't try to steal you she's like
thank you that's all i wanted because i
need to know how much you paid these
fools to go out and do this then i'm
interested you know what i mean there's
drastic graphics
half the should i do is go out they'd be
like me coming out the dope is yolo
experience with the [ __ ] weed and the
dmt and [ __ ] what what oh it's like
experiences
but it's like yo you're stepping on joe
rogan's [ __ ] yeah you should be
embarrassed
that's all that's all it's not like
we're gonna fight any like what no bro
i'm just keep talking having fun but
it's more like oh when i watch pineapple
express now i know i feel tainted
but also this all may be for not because
mine just looked this [ __ ] isn't even
out yet it might not even be it might
not even be it's not on youtube then who
really gives a [ __ ] yeah but we just
want to address it guys story time is
how to address it the youtube weed
demographic of fans on youtube
like that's us you're kind of if you're
coming on youtube it's the same space
it's the same fans
you know you got to address it that's it
that's it guys so we're not over here
being petty
being dicks and saying you know we're so
[ __ ] big and cool you got to know
about us that's not what the [ __ ] we're
talking about
and if you think that you're probably on
the wrong channel man you don't know us
very well i know it's confusing to
people you got to be a real dope as yolo
fantastic i didn't understand and know
how many times i've been [ __ ]
over
and i can't say all the companies
because i can get pissed but
you know what good example let me bring
this example up i've never talked about
this openly
because it used to piss me off are you
ready
rosie and i started push trees because i
did a picture me and rosie were smoking
a joint next door and next door was my
brother's house from the story time of
the animal's attacks that house the push
tree cells and i'm smoking a joint i go
rosie i have a great idea and she goes
what like just take the [ __ ] picture
and just make sure i'm in frame watch
this and i went put the joint in my
mouth i was smoking it and i went like
this and pretended pushing this tree as
hard as i could
and she's like what i don't get to go
push trees rosie sell weed isn't that a
funny picture
i i just thought it was funny i posted
and people go bro that was pretty
[ __ ] good push trees that's funny
and i'm going that is funny so my friend
from uh pittsburgh i had never met he
just sent me clothes his name was kush
friendly
he said
yo let's make a t-shirt let's make a
[ __ ] logo out of
out of you pushing so that's who this is
supposed to be me all right
we
the long story short we made the
sweaters we sold out in
less than 36 hours guys we were sold out
of hundreds of pieces i had forty
thousand subscribe followers on
instagram it's 2013
and he i really text me cause you might
have a brand on your hands this is this
is crazy my site crashed four times
what are you are you kidding me right
now and that's how bir push trees was
birthed you ready
four months later
i remember where i was standing when
this happened marty
four months later
i am wearing a push tree shirt i'm doing
pictures i remember what pictures the
one that had a bill cosby shirt on but
prior to the raper bill cosby
i had a bill cosby shirt on me and it
was a photoshop of him holding a [ __ ]
bag of weed i just thought it was a cool
shirt i had the shirt and i was taking a
picture
um yeah i was had the shirt i was taking
a picture i was done i remember it was
that day so i get back in my clothes i'm
wearing a push tree shirt looking at my
own clothes still like wow this is so
cool people wearing our [ __ ] so i wore
push streets every day
sorry it's a long story and i'm looking
at my phone and i get a comment
on my push trees picture and it goes
hustle trees by lrg
and my whole world crashed
i mean everything that i had worked for
went are you
[ __ ] kidding me
i forgot that lrg dropped a shirt called
hustle trees in 2008 when i was no like
2006 when i was in high school
um i saw the shirt go hustle trees i'm
like i'd buy it if i didn't say hustle i
don't i don't know where i don't know
why i just like the word hustle on my
shirt was kind of odd to me i was like a
hustle tree no it's cool but they made a
shirt a sweater and a hat
right they made a shirt or sweater and a
hat
it's not like
lrg made the brand hustle trees nothing
like that
um
but i remember seeing it going
do [ __ ] think i bit this [ __ ]
you know what i mean that's the first
thing i thought like please don't tell
me people thought i but i just copied
this [ __ ] please don't [ __ ] tell me
that because this is some [ __ ]
uh you know what i'll talk about it a
little bit these guys got pretty upset
at me
they got lg got kind of upset at me
because i told him to eat a dick
um
over this or over so one of their guys
one of their guys uh
one of the dudes at a
in person i was in person with the guy
and he's like push trees like oh yeah
it's my company he goes oh
go no not lrg we sell wheat for real and
i sold pax my life my whole life and
i just made this up just to make it up
it's a [ __ ] meme it's a [ __ ] joke
it was a joke it was just to make fun of
he was like ah so weed but when i saw
the word hustle trees i go no way please
don't i don't want people to think i
just copied their [ __ ] it was four
months later i was selling clothes hella
hyped and then someone commented hustle
tree i go oh my [ __ ] god
i forgot that they had that shirt i
forgot it's such a lesser idea than push
trees yeah
it's not even that it's like
but i swear to god i didn't go hey i'm
gonna just change the word no [ __ ]
i have the original picture it happens
in graphics that's what i thought of
when i saw the story time by seth rogen
i thought
i hope they just didn't know
you know what i mean i hope it wasn't
blatant i mean it's super like every
time you go into a creative project if
you're a professional designer you go
into it with like you do your research
first i'm selling packs at the time but
i'm saying when you're going to design a
brand you go into it doing research
first so if you now i do i google
everything before i think of a name of
something but if you have multiple
people going into the same type of
design project i mean there's there's
only so many ideas to pull from the idea
of like you know you're trying to make a
weed brand you might come out with
something similar
yeah it's not even that it's it's it's
this was 2006 that never came out again
so it's not like it was a brand it's
just like it's like me it's like me
making uh homies for life homies for
life shirt and somebody else starts
making cartoon weed and blunts like
uh you didn't steal my [ __ ] it's just
blunts man
but if you're making the exact same [ __ ]
like did you steal my [ __ ] no bro we
just like blunts oh yeah
cool same same situation the word trees
yeah same situation i get it i see other
brands that have the word tree something
trees stew tree and it's weird companies
i'm like
i hope you guys didn't take my [ __ ] but
at the same time it's just a word the
push true [ __ ] is funny though because
it's funny it's different that was the
whole point it was just funny yeah it
made me laugh the first shirts were just
it's ironic [ __ ] it's a logo it's brand
new that's what makes it a brand it's
like hustle hard yeah any nike could put
that on their [ __ ] shirt push trees
and this guy just pushing like
you stupid [ __ ] it's just funny to me
yeah but it turned into a huge i mean
there's a [ __ ] warehouse here
but that's how i was hoping i was hoping
it was like that like i never [ __ ]
looked at lrg and now i'm gonna take it
[ __ ] you yeah no suck my dick and i hope
they did the same thing with the story
time that's all so going past that we're
assuming that's what i'm assuming
assuming they just didn't realize that's
all so that that's that's where we'll
leave it at guys um
great comparison i did this
in my brain they might have did that in
their brain and it's the same thing so i
can't just be sitting here blaming
people
i'm a logical person fuck-ups
it could be anything they slapped the
[ __ ] two they put three seconds of
thought into it without doing anything
and just like what are you doing telling
stories call it story time you know why
i got story time from did i ever tell
you
just seems like an obvious title no
the reason the reason i call the story
time the reason i even thought of
stories
why do you think who who's my favorite
person on the planet [ __ ] adam
sandler what happens in billy madison
when he goes to school and he's like all
right
now it's time for story time and he sits
down the puppy that lost its way the
puppy named happy popped his puppy head
remember out of his puppy house i'm not
gonna say the whole scene i almost did
that's why i got it he's sitting there
i go whoa
what if i tell a story maybe fools would
be sitting there like that
and that's that's how i started doing
stories i [ __ ] filmed the first one
on my phone
and i was like rosie give me like 30
minutes i'm gonna try to film a video
she goes all right
that was it no mic no nothing no i had
to grow light it was a grow light on me
uh-huh i love that
yeah
there should be no other way
all my first six years with grow lights
i didn't i never bought these are the
first lights i've ever bought and that
one
they're like you're getting tan as [ __ ]
under them i was always sweating how
hard dude
um
but yes
sorry guys we're i'm a logical
[ __ ] it could have been an
accident just like then again i mean
that was 2006.
so it would have been some bitch-ass
[ __ ] if we didn't say [ __ ] though so
yeah if we didn't say [ __ ] we would have
been like oh yeah
give me your cornbread yeah sorry mr
celebrity sorry celebrity uh
we haven't been you know it's crazy i i
i was thinking the other day i posted on
twitter guys sorry how long we've been
here what the [ __ ] am i doing how long
about 20 30. oh okay cool let's my spark
is joint i was thinking
i don't think and i say it with
confidence
i think we have the most loyal fan base
of any human
in the world
can you think of another person that has
fans that are so [ __ ] dope and
dedicated
and watch every [ __ ] weekend in the
chats and the premieres doing
do you know what i'm saying i've worked
with a lot of entertainers wild and not
even close not even super super famous
ones it's a different kind of
relationship not even close and i can't
even explain the relationship to a lot
of them
because it takes too long to build it's
too organic it takes years of it's like
a friend but yeah it's like watching
somebody grow though because the so much
of your fan base has been around for so
long that they appreciate how far you've
come with this they remember they
remember that [ __ ] the little grow
lights and toys on my [ __ ] lawn
taking pictures of the ball all these
mini wins up the ladder yeah you know
everything it takes to do all this [ __ ]
so that's why it's different and because
you talk to them directly commit your
one it's like yo you do it too try it
yeah dude you know how many people i've
met go bro i used to watch your [ __ ] and
that so-and-so video is why i started
this i met a lot of people in booths i'm
getting that too a lot of people at
booth's like yo
i can't believe i'm meeting you bro
you're the way i started this [ __ ]
company yeah we've been talking about
it's so sick we've been talking about
trying to be more deliberate about
helping people [ __ ] like that because we
get so many damn me now with the
videographers graphic designers bro i'm
going back to school i i quit my [ __ ]
[ __ ] job because i know i want to
get after and be a graphic designer all
this [ __ ]
we want to just figure out the best way
to be able to do yes the best way to
extend extend that helping
hand i guess you would say
yeah yeah
you know trial and error you've done 10
years i've done 10 years i would love to
tell you guys hey don't don't do that
just go to that person don't go to that
[ __ ] you know what i mean how cool
would it be to save you two bands the
only way to really know some [ __ ] is to
go out and do it like we just had an uh
expert we've i study sound proofing and
all this nerdy audio [ __ ] all the time
constantly
but we just had a real expert dude who's
done it before come through and advise
us on a bunch of [ __ ] we would never
thought of
because you don't know until you get out
there and do it he's smart so anytime
you have somebody experienced really
willing to drop yeah work for mushrooms
he said which was really [ __ ] cool
[Music]
you don't pay me he's like just give me
some money i got you
because he asked us can you get some
mushrooms
yeah yeah i'll just pay you in much
yeah we got the coolest like
construction crew people the
construction dude is a [ __ ]
psychedelic enthusiast shout out to
steve sound guy came through we'll get
paid in mushrooms anybody else like
drugs
does anybody
does anybody have like a company that
just pays your rent and i'll just give
you drugs
well you have a [ __ ] car rap company
that likes trucks
that's pretty call erican he knows all
these businesses yeah like yo eric
do you got a boba tea spa that takes
mushrooms
i used to trade weed for everything
it was so fun
it's the best
i love it i love doing that [ __ ] i just
got to find a super bomb vegan spot
that's like yo just bring me an ace
gotcha yeah gotcha [ __ ]
um
yeah so i just wanted to talk about that
we addressed it
we addressed it here we go what time are
we at
uh right around 30. this has to be
edited in one day guys so we are not
going to before [ __ ] three hours
nothing like that today
today's episode
i was thinking of a way of structuring
this
more themed
so
today is going to be about college
i went to college as you know for five
years to a two-year school and i haven't
graduated because i'm an [ __ ]
you ready
i don't think i've ever told this story
on the podcast you tell me yes or no
substitute teacher
college getting arrested no here we go
those are fresh keywords
i just gave you the keywords exactly
so guys
here we go
story time let's get ready what exact
time are we at
31 on the board here okay i'm gonna try
to keep this like 20 minutes
we'll see you all that
all right cool ready here we go
merced community college is where
dreams go to die
that's where your efforts and goals go
to you know what i'm just gonna do meth
all right mercedes community college
sucks dick
and if you're there now it's awesome
finish all right
here we go here we go merced community
college ready go
i
rare occasion
you guys know i had straight f's
i don't care about school and then my
mom says hey i'll give you a hundred
dollars for every a you get
remember i told i don't know if i told
you that story
and i got straight a's for two years
straight math student of the year four
points four or eight uh
four semesters in a row eight quarters
four points don't give me an incentive i
spend it all on football cards all right
anyway uh she says i'll pay you for
every hey you get and i go oh you [ __ ]
up and i was all the gifted programs
i've been in all the crowbar malcolm in
the middle my whole life right
so i'm sitting there going oh i'm going
to try now
so i got straight a's fast forward to
ninth grade
no more incentive and i got f's
till today here we go
i'm in college i don't give a [ __ ] about
school but i know this one english class
i have to have to do this report
i have to support if i want to pass the
class this is one of the few semesters i
really tried to finish my stuff i really
really really tried to finish school
so i didn't have a computer so i am at
the push trees house before this is
before i met rosie man this before i met
rosie i was still just living with jebus
it's after class and i decided to go to
college to use the computer that's
dedication for me and i can go sell zips
instead
you're lucky i showed up
i go to i go after school after my
classes
extracurricular learning at this point i
go i plug in my it was a dog tag but it
was a usb but it looked like a dog tag
and i also thought it was the coolest i
still have it i plug it in i'm like
all right [ __ ] let me write this
[ __ ] five page essay real quick it's
only five pages it's [ __ ] nothing
and it's a computer lab you walk into a
computer lab there's what 80 computers
it's spread out through like a half a
costco size but you know it's a [ __ ]
computer lab
and on the very very very far end
there's a classroom using computers if
there's 100 computers 15 are being used
16 because of me
here's the doorway i walk in and pick
the first computer because i'm like i'm
not even i don't want to be here as it
is first computer [ __ ] this the guys are
in the exact opposite corner
i'm sitting there i start going all
right cool
tab space uh my name you know the date
and all that [ __ ]
i get through my day nothing i get right
there and i see this tall white dude
in a regular ass shirt and sweats
sweatpants
and he's in the middle of the day and
he's in sweats all right
he's walking through he's walking and
he's looking at me and i'm like i'm
ignoring i could see this [ __ ]
come from i'm aware of my surroundings
and and this guy's coming like all right
what do you want and i can see him like
30 feet away looking at me i'm like ah
[ __ ] this
and i'm trying to type
and he comes up to me and stands right
[ __ ] here
i'm sitting down he's like six three his
dick is right by my shoulder and i'm
just like
hello
i was just i was
like you're in my space you're in my
space [ __ ] you get it out of my
space
and i was like that
hello
and he goes why are you in my classroom
i go
huh it's a computer lab he goes why are
you in my class like i'm not in your
class exactly get out of my class i go
i'm not
in your classroom because this is my
computer lab time i booked this time
this is my class i'm like dude
there's 75 empty computers i'm trying to
do my work i can't use this it goes no
get out and come out come back when it's
not your time when it's
go he said get out and come back on your
time go this is my time like no my
computer lab and i go you're a teacher
he's wearing sweats and a shirt on it
and high top laced converse i go you're
a teacher you could have been more than
25 that's what you look like probably
didn't work there's probably some creep
coming in on the [ __ ] computer here's
a [ __ ] teacher
okay and i go you're a teacher he goes
yes my classroom get out and i go
bro
let me unplug this and i'll leave
and he just stood there and crossed his
arms and waited for me
and i went like this i press eject on my
chip i'm pressing eject i press the x on
powerpoint or whatever the [ __ ] i was
using and he goes why are you still here
just like that you see that face that's
the face i had like
and i looked at him like i'm trying to
get my [ __ ] usb chip out of here
what's wrong with you and he goes get
out of my [ __ ] classroom and i looked
at him i go get the i started getting
upset
in the glass room there's another
computer part it's all closed there's a
glass room of all computers and then the
rest that we're using so there's a full
class and right right here the rest are
all empty and then his class on the
other side
and i see everybody like
oh
and i'm like yo get the [ __ ] away from
me all right let me get back into this
mode
you're the teacher and i'm looking at my
yo get the [ __ ] away from me and he
looks at me he goes i'm gonna call the
front go call the phone i was all call
the front [ __ ] what the [ __ ] wrong
with you you're in my [ __ ] space i'm
trying to educate myself i'm trying to
[ __ ] learn and you're telling me to
leave the computer class and i don't
have a computer
not my problem get out of the classroom
and i go
get away from me i was like take a step
[ __ ] back for me and he took a step
back and i unplugged my [ __ ] i'm putting
it away and he steps up to where if i
stood up i
like
you know what i'm saying when someone
stands so close to you if you stood
straight up you bump into them you know
what i mean like they're not he's not
towering over me but he's like
leaning over my space
like he's gonna punch me or something or
like he's a authority figure
and i remember thinking like
i'm gonna snap your [ __ ] arm like i'm
gonna grab it and i'm gonna step on it
i'm gonna i was just so [ __ ]
frustrated i can remember thinking like
if this guy's not a teacher i'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of him
and then
i go to stand up
and he's in my space i was like get the
[ __ ] out of my space and he looks at me
and he just starts getting on a cell
phone he's like i'm calling the [ __ ]
uh what are they called liaisons or the
officers of the school so i'm calling
the liaison like [ __ ] call the
liaisons and then i don't know what came
over me man i'm an
[ __ ] but like a smart i'm a funny
[ __ ]
anything you do beyond this point
doesn't make you an [ __ ] oh no no i
mean [ __ ] in like a oh you're such a
dick bro good job
i don't know what came over me i get my
backpack on and i'm looking at him
because he's tall and i'm looking at him
and i start walking and he's on yes i'm
in the live with someone so this is uh
so and so it's like professor blah blah
like yo this guy's a real teacher are
you [ __ ] dress better is what i kept
thinking
i get to the door remember it's the
first computer so i get five feet away i
get away to the door i open it i turn
around and i'm like
nice sweats [ __ ] i don't know why i was
like nice sweats [ __ ]
and you could see the imaginary single
tear leave this full [ __ ] as this entire
clap they're already standing up the
classroom standing up like oh [ __ ] when
i was like get the [ __ ] away from me
everybody look like whoa
that kid's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
our substitute teacher and then as i
said that all i can see behind him and
all the kids in that classroom were like
remember we're in college these aren't
kids i say kids because we're younger
but
and i remember thinking like dude don't
hit this guy there's so many people here
that are gonna go oh yeah he hit the
teacher
and i'm nice sweats [ __ ] single tear
world star style eruption of laughter
i mean
to where i felt like oh guys gosh shut
the [ __ ] up
his whole classroom
fool's running around [ __ ] tables and
[ __ ]
i'm looking at him and i can see him
look at me like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna cry
i could see it on his face like [ __ ] i
knew i shouldn't wear these damn sweats
today
and then i saw all the people in the
glass classroom like
like laughing their ass off and as the
door closes behind me i hear
and then it closes and the laughter's
gone
and i remember strapping my backpack and
go well i'm about to be in trouble
i embarrassed the man so bad there's no
way he's letting this go
i'm not
nearly done
that's just the first of three parts you
ready all right
scene one
scene one act one act two coming ready
go
me walking
walk
go to the quad and as halfway through
the quad i'm like i'm gonna call this
the police of the thing and let him know
like
yo this teacher had an altercation i'm
just letting you know nothing crazy
happened we added words and just that's
it
i'm walking i call them and they go oh
we actually just had that teacher
calling oh yeah he got my space he was
towering over me man i told him get the
[ __ ] away from me i didn't touch him i
just walked off i'm just letting you
guys know my name is thomas ferrajo i
don't want you guys to come in my
classroom and pull me out or something
crazy
and i say i'm gonna be in the middle of
the quad by the little uh bulletin board
thing i'll be right there if you guys
need to talk to me because i know that
guy's super [ __ ] mad
and they go no don't worry man all good
and i wait there for about five minutes
four minutes later
a [ __ ] cop car the cop car of the
school this guy drove through the
[ __ ] quad at 20 miles an hour
like i had a gun
guy drove through the quad
through the quad
break right in front of me i did this me
i'm the guy
your hand you're flagging them down i
went
but i was like that's [ __ ]
driving fast is it for is this for me
he gets out the car you screams at me
comes up and grabs my [ __ ] shirt both
hands grabs me and throws me face first
on the [ __ ] car on the hood of the
car hold on in the day in the middle of
school so how many people are staring
watching this happen to
me i see them a lot adults adults are
watching me get manhandled and he i was
like officer he's like you and went oh
and i was like i'm the guy that bam grab
me [ __ ] dipped me chest and chin
right on the thing
i've never been the cop's never done
that to me i've always avoided that
i've always avoided being caught like
that and this [ __ ] and i didn't
do nothing
slam me on my [ __ ] and handcuff me right
then and there
right my hands are under my backpack
because i have a backpack on because i'm
trying to be a student i was trying cars
full of weed and scales i have baggies
everything's in my car and i kept
thinking thomas don't say i'm stupid bro
cause your car has a hell of [ __ ]
and
let's just be let's see how this goes
he turns me around he's like so you're
like punching teachers how [ __ ]
and i went
what the [ __ ] no i went what the [ __ ]
did you just say cuz i just got a call
from a substitute teacher saying you hit
him and left the building and i go
are you [ __ ] with me i'm the guy that
called you he goes wait
you're the one that called me go i'm the
one that called you and said nothing
happened i'll be at the bulletin board
oh
oh okay
change this whole tone
he spoke to me i said i am a student my
name is
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
turns me around i'm all shake i'm pissed
turns me around goes
i'm just kidding man he didn't say you
hit him i just want to scare you and
that pissed me off even more and i went
oh
and in my head i'm like
daddy's in your car bro shut the [ __ ] up
and i'm like oh okay he unhandcuffed me
who are these dudes oh that's act three
handcuff unhandcuffs me and he's like so
you can't be yelling at teachers like i
go sir i came off he stood over me
almost his dick to my shoulder he stood
over me and when i tried to stand up i
bumped into him because he was so close
to me he's like oh yeah he didn't tell
us any of that he just said you were
being disruptive and threatened him and
you left
like wow
all right here we go super sick and i go
why'd you handcuff me i just wanted to
scare you i go but you know i'm kind of
embarrassed man i'm around everybody
that goes to school with me now they
think i said something and you
unhandcuffed me i'm the guy that sells
weed this is not a good look
this isn't a good look for me thinking
like hey thomas i thought you were in
trouble like nah
i told on you're homie it's not a
goddamn factor yeah [ __ ] life exactly
some fear factor [ __ ]
and i look down at him and i'm like oh
okay officer that's fine and he doesn't
recognize me i work at me and ed's he
orders every [ __ ] friday the same
pizza guy still doesn't recognize me
that i'm the pizza driver that delivers
his pizza every [ __ ] week it's the
same cop i deliver every week friday
pepperoni
i'll get onto that that's act three
i'm talking to him like oh you don't
recognize me at huh
i put my dick on your pizza that's not
what i'm i didn't really gonna do that
but i was like i'm gonna do something
but i didn't but
oh this joint went out i'm so irritated
by this [ __ ] story sorry um
so
he's talking to me giving me a lecture
even though he should be talking to the
[ __ ] guy about wearing converse to
school when you're the professor and
sweats he looked like he just got there
and woke up
so we're talking
and i'm like okay officer i'm gonna
leave
excuse me
he tells me not to go back to the
computer lab for the rest of the week
because that guy has it for the rest of
the week and i go okay so i'll go to the
public library then and use the [ __ ]
computer since i'm not allowed to be
educated i was just kind of like
i feel played but i'm not going to say
anything because i sell weed at the
school so i'm going to just shut the
[ __ ] up
and
i go home super [ __ ] heated
that's a thursday
tomorrow is a pizza day for this man act
three
i pull up i know exactly what he orders
and guys i deliver pizza this guy weekly
for a year
there's only so many times you can do
this
um i'll get you the tip next time
he doesn't recognize me and he says the
same excuse every time about the tip i
don't give a [ __ ] if you don't tip me
i'm not a kid bro don't lie to me every
week i don't want your tip lee keep your
tip he does this
uh i'll get you next time
that's fine sir and it got to the point
where i just hand the pizza and walk
away so you just stop doing that like on
some home alone yeah oh gum
you sure you want the tip and the next
one's a stack that's not the situation
that happened to me it was always just
gum
and um
i don't care about the tip but it was
like
you cuffed me and threw me in my face
yesterday you know he goes sir you don't
recognize me all right [ __ ] you and i
just kept thinking like you really not
see that it's me
the same kid you slammed yesterday these
are skills security cops they are actual
cops okay and they just happen to work
at the school okay they have a police
station and everything
i pull up the same time same day for the
pizza the same pizza you were just one
one topping pizza
and paid me 10.99 exactly every [ __ ]
time and it's like it's cool bro it's i
don't care if you'd hit me but don't do
this number
it's like yo there's not even a wallet
spot i was thinking about that i was
thinking like why do you why do you
reach right here well like it's just a
badge and um
that's the time at college
where i got a little played
man these these [ __ ]
adults would be getting cancelled these
days
i felt so violated
yeah you got to be such a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] to do that's like to get tough
with a
student trying to just be on the
computer bro i was just trying to
actually do my work i failed that class
i was i couldn't imagine you sitting
there trying to type you sit in there
typing some report is hilarious like i'm
super good at writing
reports are where i get that c-minus
because i don't do my homework i don't
do nothing else but i'll write that
[ __ ] report
and uh yeah i'm good i'm good at writing
but
i just remember thinking like the one
time i try mm-hmm
and i'm stopped i tell you the one time
i tried to vote when i was younger i
tried to vote and they told me you're on
the wrong side of town this is not your
jurisdiction and they told me to leave
and i went well i'm not voting in there
again
you're on the wrong side of town [ __ ]
you
we're set's three miles long
oh my god so that's another time
authorities played me but anyway the
teacher [ __ ] you um
you bump into him again or i couldn't
tell you what he faced right now you
look like a regular white you look like
shaggy with no hair
from scooby-doo
and i love converse but i just wanted to
make fun of him can't be a teacher in
sweatpants it's down there oh you can't
not and not tell people [ __ ] like who's
gonna believe you you know you're a town
full of gangsters right they're gonna
beat your [ __ ] ass maybe i was the
only nice kid to try to confront that's
why what i'm assuming cause like [ __ ] i
kept thinking like dude
how are you alive yeah
nobody stabbed you he's used to being
like uh see you gotta [ __ ] watch one
eight seven he's used to being [ __ ]
sick okay samuel l jackson he's dealing
with the [ __ ] uh his 25 year old wife
are you done kid yeah remember the three
kids the kid who chopped his finger off
he's used to dealing with that [ __ ]
kid
yes
great movie guys
pissed me the [ __ ] off
i think the slamming on the hot hood
really pissed me off though uh yeah
that's some [ __ ] you i mean what the
[ __ ] that really wasn't just to scare
you like i just wanted to punch you a
little bit that's exactly what he said i
was just trying to scare you man you
can't be yelling at teachers
i'm an adult
teachers he's five years older than me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
um
so marty what did you do in college
man my college days were [ __ ]
short-lived
it was i wasn't in there that long at
all how long did you go to school only
uh three semesters totally probably a
little bit less than three it's a long
time
i mean i guess
on-site i mean i went back after online
and did this [ __ ] but
my first two were just i was i was still
super militant from high school as far
as like
being super super super disciplined my
first year at college when i was playing
basketball you know i was working a
full-time job i was maybe not not
full-time but it was like on some [ __ ] i
was the only kid commuting i'm driving
up there probably 20 minutes 30 minutes
in the snow and traffic and [ __ ]
get there at like 5 30 in the morning
we're on the track pre-season running
around the track working out
then either school all day or work all
day
flip flop alternate days then back for
practice then we eat together then we
got to study and do homework together
and like how you're talking about in the
[ __ ] computer lab
and then i'd commute home and then that
drive back then like i was doing that
for the first full i was on i had like
dean's list or whatever you call it my
first year because i was just on
i don't remember a [ __ ] thing about
it but i was just so used to being
super disciplined still from high school
but it was the second i let go of the
steering wheel that discipline started
smoking weed and [ __ ] and just not being
completely disciplined
fell apart our friends here
the story about how you uh did you get
kicked out of college
yeah i think i kind of got into that i
mean i basically kicked myself out of
college over
the time that i got
yeah you told me to sloppy drunk and
then they
pin the weed on me i kept lying about it
making up crazy stories other kids on
the team were [ __ ]
snitching me out for it and [ __ ]
and uh then i had to go to do community
service i actually did this how dumb i
am i did the community service and they
quit school
basically and then the coach was like
all right we're going to have you back
on like he's like jesus [ __ ] christ
you're making me look bad out here i can
tell it's what he's looking at what he's
thinking they [ __ ] basically
recruited me to come there i did the
whole preseason grueling workouts all
that [ __ ] all right we're gonna come
down and have a meeting with us and i
just [ __ ] blew them off i was like i
just didn't go and it's not it's not
even me
but i just didn't care anymore also was
the other thing so then they were like
yeah you're off the [ __ ] team and i
didn't give a [ __ ] and then i just it
was when i was dealing with g when it
really heavy so i'm like already not
knowing what the [ __ ] is going on at
that point i'm coming up there high as
[ __ ] now
half the time i come up there put my
hand on the door and just uh i [ __ ]
turn around and leave and go back and
chill and [ __ ]
so i was getting all these calls and
[ __ ] i kept leaving out of the classroom
to take music calls and [ __ ] and i just
stopped going
i was in the the
one semester i was there i was in the
dorm though which was [ __ ] funny
because i couldn't imagine
with other people that are my age yeah
but it was my hometown i was still i was
in [ __ ] next to delaware park where
me and jamal lived literally i could hit
throw a football and [ __ ] hit this
school it was right on the [ __ ]
the dead end street ended at the school
that i'm at now gotcha so i'm right
where i live so like i was the kid i had
all these [ __ ] like kids are looking
at them like gangsters up in my dorm
room and [ __ ] they're looking at me
crazy up there oh yeah i'm going got
producers bringing me beats and [ __ ] and
we're all in there hanging out like it's
my [ __ ] mom's basement but it's the
dorm room and the kid the other kids
from the dorm i would kick you out
i would kick you out was he bringing 60
heads here they don't go to school
yeah and then they'd be like or i'll
just never be there at times too i'd
just be out and they'd be like dude like
you're never here they told my
girlfriend at the time like he's never
here i don't know where he's at but
[ __ ] i'm out here i was out i was that
was my very beginnings of like as soon
as i got into music bam now i'm
interning at a studio deep thinker
records like this backpacking [ __ ]
underground hip-hop
uh
label studio on the west side
it's just how i am one up there
right away now i'm interning there bam
right you know as i'm doing school as
i'm falling off basketball and all this
[ __ ] started going to all the
underground hip-hop shows and learning
how to engineer in there and it was
[ __ ] over i just [ __ ] off school
you know to the point that i just racked
up a bunch of debt and then went back
later
but
i was i was an [ __ ] though that was
the only time i ever cheated on one of
my girlfriends
was in that stretch
oh no it's going crazy in the dorms i
was going crazy in the dorms
this is full
good choice of words i guess i was going
crazy
yeah who did you have to live with
did you get did you get to pick him no
we just no it was this kid who lived in
the country like you're saying shaggy
but he looked like [ __ ] he just
looked like shaggy full-blown and he was
just
goofy regular teenage kid like no big
deal how did you feel about having a
bunch of gang bangers in this i don't
think on his back he didn't he didn't
really like it all that much i don't
think he was a little bit i keep hearing
mad real world vibes yes what did i do
you stabbed my dad
a little bit a little bit like that
who do you know here oh it's my bed yeah
that was real it was it was kind of like
that i remember one time i had remember
the girl from the parking lot the story
i told you you put a gun on her face yes
no no no the bb gun story where she was
scared exactly what i just said
so that was watered down [ __ ]
that's exactly what you guys did
yeah so we're in the dorm room one time
hey guess come by marty's gonna put a
pistol in your [ __ ] face that's what
it sounds like
sorry you're at the dorms go
me and this girl are
me and this girl are going ham just but
the kids in the room asleep and i
couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing i
remember this she's just going ham i'm
because i'm fat off your back
literally just like we were talking
about that with lysol and charlie lysol
it's my homie lysol he just got out the
joint she couldn't understand why i
couldn't stop laughing the fact that you
were laughing
while this kid's asleep in your dorm and
you're with a girl makes me love the
story more
the fact that she's like what's wrong
why are you laughing at me no no i'm
thinking of this chappelle show
right now
that was right at that time you stabbed
my dad
oh my god
yeah
i had sex with katie too man
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's been 15 years
and i'm still quoting it every day i
guarantee you if i go on any gift i've
sent anybody in the past five days it's
all chappelle show [ __ ] still
[Music]
there's a character for each mood of
life yes
god i love that [ __ ] show
that's what you were doing so you were
laughing at
your friend that's asleep well i had a
girlfriend and she was cool but i didn't
really like her like we worked at the
mall together
i just she was cute and we worked at the
mall together so i'm like
it becomes like you know not
a thing i'm this girl's gonna end up
being my girlfriend i had a stretch
where i was like all right
if i decide that i like you where you're
gonna end up being my girlfriend i just
was shot great percentage from the line
with girls that i wanted
like
thousand percent
so i started to just i don't know why we
just became happy yeah
girlfriend
i took her to toronto i was a really
nice dude to her we're in toronto
and i started finding out she's got some
she's like
basically like yeah i've been with like
20 25 dudes
just
throughout the course and i'm we're like
19.
and i was like
she's getting around i had no
she started just casually yeah yeah drop
well meanwhile we're on a we're on the
first time ever i've driven to like
toronto by myself
because i just turned 19.
and we went for my [ __ ] birthday it
was that story i was telling where my
cousin came with the car gave me the
computer the whole [ __ ] this is all that
fun
wow this is the day you started graphics
basically yeah yeah i mean yeah am i at
19
to you for having a bad personality that
made marty go oh you're with me i'm just
going to start doing photoshop
so shout out to her man
but i'm kidding by the way lady i never
cheated on any of my girlfriends me and
her were kind of like lukewarm but she
would come up to the dorms and [ __ ]
and like stay the night at the dorms i
was only in there for a semester so this
is not a big stretch time
and then there's this girl two doors
down in the same dorm
that
was just like a [ __ ] savage she was
basically just like super upfront about
it she said can i talk to you
and she was just like just laid it all
out there and [ __ ] like i don't know if
you got a girlfriend or whatever but i'm
just i'm just if you want to
come back to like maybe tomorrow or
something like
was she cool
kinda [ __ ] i was it was cool that's cool
she was like she had her own she must
have she had her own dorm room her
parents got money yeah
none other girl none of the other girls
on the floor like this [ __ ]
they don't like her no their dad sells
drugs something like it was something
she was the only kid that i knew of in
the school all i'm thinking of now is
how high but continue
yeah so i ended up cheating on my
girlfriend who was coming up to the
dorms pretty like [ __ ] frequently
with this girl
that lives right two doors down
and the girl didn't give a [ __ ] the girl
was like properly
so short it only happened like maybe
twice and then i broke up like it was
just one of those situations with a girl
whereas like we both like this isn't
anything really so i'm just i feel like
a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] doing this
so then i was kind of border i mean now
i'm just kind of like
with not with this girl at the [ __ ]
two doors down but then crazy from the
[ __ ] park a lot stops coming to the
dorm and [ __ ] so it was it was chaotic i
could not thinking about it from my
perspective my roommate's perspective
thank you so much yeah oh we should have
started this with i went to college for
three semesters there's a guy out there
still recovering from some of this [ __ ]
that's just one semester during sweden
yeah and then yeah we had the scenario
the the scenario where we got caught
with the weed that was a whole [ __ ]
thing too you were a [ __ ] face drunk
i have pictures from my it wasn't even
an iphone of that night
on my [ __ ] in my [ __ ] because i had
never even i had really never been drunk
before
really i mean
not really i mean no not like that but
you we're just straight
vodka like just
nothing else and i remember my
girlfriend at the time she's talking to
one of the roommates
and i'm like looking at her this was
before i knew she was all [ __ ] out
there like that i'm like
this dude could probably get with her
right now if you wanted to just why i'm
just staying i'm right in front of him
just watching and he speaks spanish
she's all into spanish and i'm like wow
i could see how this could [ __ ] go
right now this is crazy
so then when she said no i know then
when she told me that i was like damn
this is kind of like starting to [ __ ]
add up here i'm piecing these meanwhile
like i'm thinking this girl's my [ __ ]
girlfriend and she was i mean it only
lasted probably
two months month and a half one of those
odd yeah
but
even with that i would say probably
almost every girlfriend i've been with
would speak
positively of me that girl just had no
clue about anything i just said so aside
from that until right now she's a fan
patreon subscriber
and she just uh
re-uh funded her money uh-huh yeah one
time i bumped it i was in this pizza
shop with april right when that like we
were a new couple and like bumped into
this girl and i got super like oh like i
didn't know what the [ __ ] to say for a
second
i've never had to do that i'm so happy
i've waited my whole life and never
dated anybody
first off my mom would beat the [ __ ] out
of me and then she's like wait you're 16
or you can't and she's all punching your
[ __ ] face
it was worse than being gangster was
getting a girlfriend that's actually why
we have kids yeah and it scared me too
you know how many people have kids
in my town i'm saying all this thinking
like thank [ __ ] god
thank god
thank god i was like every time a girl
talking i go
you look like you get pregnant and i'm
good
i'm good i dude i've never dated anybody
so i've never had that feeling of like
oh [ __ ] i should date that girl ever i
was dating i started dating her like 15
probably
so
steady girlfriends basically the whole
time i've never once
i've actually just like got myself out
of situations with girls because i was
like uh no i'm good [ __ ] no i get that
she propositioned me say anything like
no thanks guys uh-huh yeah yeah see i
was i didn't have that yeah you get my
mad dog 20 20. yep go away blue
raspberry hole
you really just didn't give a [ __ ]
that's funny like weed was not my life
not at all
i just know like
for what so you can get pregnant yeah
for what oh my god no thanks my first
girlfriend was a [ __ ] freak too we
were like
kids kids
she looked like she was like 20 though
but you know and she was like black girl
raging bisexual at this age
right like
sophomore in high school whatever it is
we are
and uh yeah we'd be walking like you
said bisexual but it was raging
aggressively
it's not a disease
like no [ __ ]
maybe it's not for you she was on it
there's probably a different level of
course there is like she was just
aggressive because she was like my
really damn near my first time losing my
virginities with her and another her
friend
the first time that means i lost it
three times three times i lost my
appreciation
kind of yeah i mean the first yeah the
first time got [ __ ] up
but yeah i guess
you know buffalo's different
no i lost my virginity on the east side
i didn't lose my buffalo
man literally my
though it almost was like that
because [ __ ]
this sounds [ __ ] crazy
we're up in the attic and [ __ ] while
this is going on
jamel's down on the main floor
and then he starts he like
shouts up something like
told your mom what's going on she's
coming to get you so i'm coming to pick
you up or some [ __ ] he like yelled that
up
he like opened the door up to the attic
rip on the [ __ ] air mattress and [ __ ]
shout that up close the door
like [ __ ] did your mom really show up
yeah
oh so he was helping you out no he was
[ __ ] wait he said he said i told her
what's going on yeah
i'm sorry bro but that's some haters i'm
like
you're up there and said oh but throw up
throw up stay right here yeah marty come
help me no he was [ __ ] hating on me
yeah no
like that's the way to help out funny
yeah he thought it was [ __ ] kind of
funny no it's [ __ ]
but it was funny before because the [ __ ]
i was i think i might have told you
about this the [ __ ] kicked off at the
[ __ ]
martin lawrence
movie
i've never heard the story ladies and
gentlemen i've never heard it because
you started off with mar lawrence no i
haven't heard the story no well first of
all in my mind i'm named after martin
lawrence marty's middle name is lawrence
his first name is martin so he says
martin lawrence
o'neil yeah
but we went to
we went to see his movie he put out a
stand-up movie run tell that yeah so if
you're from buffalo we're at the [ __ ]
delaware right across from delaware park
there the regal it was new
we were walking up there that's they got
the target right next to it what did you
hear like the footsteps on the roof i
didn't hear your shot sorry
you're at delaware park you better watch
this movie
yeah uh
so me and her friend
go to see this martin lawrence movie
and she's into her friend that we're
bringing
oh because she's bisexual yeah so it's
almost more about her friend than it is
even me yo you should have like a towel
around your neck and a [ __ ]
championship belt
just going like that like yo i started
off young
real fast
that's [ __ ] awesome continue yeah
people looked at us crazy too because
she looked like a model she looked like
[ __ ] brandy or something like she
looked like a model
like a grown woman damn near i look like
a boy
i got blessed
when we walked into the theater and i
saw only other people in the theater
were my boys i played basketball with
that's the top
oh that was damn marty's crushing it
yeah
oh you went back to school like you got
a new [ __ ] you're the first guy with
a ps5 that's how cool you were when you
went back to school like damn that
[ __ ] had two different girls
with them yesterday uh-huh that's what
got a ps5 already same like but it was
just like in the dorm room though cause
like she's your homies are right there
she's trying to like start going all ham
in the theater and i'm all i'm thinking
about is i'm in france
yes
they're like back center we're like just
asking like yo get in the [ __ ] front
you should have switched spots with them
if they're your real friends they
weren't my real friends though they were
just the kids i played basketball with
oh never mind
yeah and we were just like the only ones
in this theater
and then um yeah so she started i mean
it directly went from the [ __ ] movie
back to the house and then
you know i mean jamal [ __ ] hated him
both of those girls were in your room
when he hated on you
just the one was oh but because she was
trying to get real active with the girl
in the movie theater the girl wasn't
really all into it she thought she was
gonna hang out with martin
yeah she thought she was going out with
like her friend and her boyfriend
meanwhile
she's got me in between them and she's
trying to get at the girl so i mean that
was my first that was like my [ __ ]
story
i'mma dunk on you when i see you
yo could you imagine those guys go
yo that [ __ ] martial [ __ ] marty's
a champion uh-huh
that was not feeling like a g at all
about it though this [ __ ] was like
[ __ ] hilarious to me it's funny
though no it's just funny because you're
a kid yeah so when you're a kid and that
happens like yeah that man's fully grown
with kids already or something what the
[ __ ] is going on she was so much like we
would be in the like she had
she's a black girl but she lives out in
the suburbs like in the sense like she
has a really nice house her parents have
her [ __ ] together her stepdad kind of
rare for buffalo right probably i don't
know i never dated a girl in that
scenario oh you haven't dated suburbian
girl yet well i mean not like that i
mean
i guess like you just you're the ghetto
part
yeah i mean for a lot of the time that i
lived there yeah but you know maybe you
don't necessarily see like i don't know
something
type of pairing this get away that's
what i'm saying like
yeah yeah she like really had her [ __ ]
together you always say like buffalo is
[ __ ] poor yeah that's why i'm
assuming there's a big disparity between
you know if you were to go into the
neighborhoods in lacawana versus where
this [ __ ] girl lived out in amherst
for people that understand east amherst
by ub the colleges this is like
probably the nicest area in buffalo
anyway
her parents would be driving us around
we're [ __ ] 15. i don't even have my
license yet
she's doing [ __ ] in the back seat and
we're talking about you know her
stepdad's this giant dude i'm [ __ ] 15
and he would like he would [ __ ] with me
a little bit like here try this catfish
but he put [ __ ]
hell of hot sauce on it
great right like at a restaurant he did
some [ __ ] like that a couple times
that's [ __ ] fine you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] my pants i was i didn't have it
i was 15 i didn't know anything yet
you know what i mean so [ __ ] take it
back you're in the car and she's doing
[ __ ] what is that she's trying to make
out with you no she's like jerking me
off in the [ __ ] back seat while her
dad's driving that type of [ __ ]
to the point where it's like i'm 15. i'm
not gonna stop her but at the same time
i'm not even paying attention to her i'm
just
hoping [ __ ] marcelo's wily in the
front
doesn't turn around
he's got a band-aid on the back of his
phone
that's the one of the most disgusting
things i've heard that girl is
disgusting showing that in the car like
oh yeah oh your dad yeah it was a lot at
15.
but she was like yeah forever my first
technically even though really like
literally if it was like a [ __ ] seth
rogen movie how the [ __ ] played out like
some super bad [ __ ] when
as jamal yells up to me in that moment
and [ __ ]
to me [ __ ] oh getting the [ __ ] out
getting her out
that was a movie also
that was kind of gross have you used the
movie kids
i know it i i've parodied the poster
before there it is there it is that's
what you remind me of all right man
you east coast kids are different man
that was nasty but then i we'd be like
walking past the court at delaware park
and [ __ ] sometimes and like everybody'd
be hollering at her the whole court
would be [ __ ] hollering at her and
[ __ ] oh and the times that i'm not
and then they're mad like who's this
woody harrelson [ __ ] dating this
girl oh he dunked on me [ __ ]
oh damn he just wrapped my brain away
all right bro good job [ __ ] you
it's probably like that
i was like me when i had my long hair
and i was wearing like my little preppy
shirts and i was [ __ ] oh yes play
basketball oh do the fall under the
under the wrist thing yeah that's oh
that's the
that's the ult that's the ultimate when
you get somebody do the oh on their
wrist like
yeah
yeah and i missed
i'm gonna miss every time but i might
make you fall to the [ __ ] floor
it's possible it's possible i might
possibly you're gonna think i shot it
but it's actually i mean
it's gonna fall down and then get into
my shirt and then i'm gonna go
and pass it to that guy
hot sauce where's hot sauce that get him
on the three-on-three tournament man
[ __ ] where's hot sauce i bet you we can
get the professor to come down here
thomas learns basketball the professor's
popping he's got [ __ ] 50 million
followers love the professor bro since i
was a kid and escalade and 50 and all
these [ __ ]
who was that
skip to my lou oh yeah or he went to the
nba for of course yeah he's a legend
yeah no he had a real career i was just
watching the other day you know i've i
love and one [ __ ] so much
so we went from college
to marty being molested to skip to my
lou that was a that was my that was that
time frame i know i understand mine was
uh
i could never the one i couldn't get was
the kobe move the
oh yeah my arms are little like
like i'm fat dude so it's like
and then it bounces back and you catch
it you're putting yourself in the balls
i always just hit me in the inner leg
and it was over yeah
but that was my [ __ ] and the one because
i could i could you obviously know we've
seen the videos we've done it before but
when i was into basketball my thing i
could not get was the you know just
doing cross through your leg and then do
the thing where you hop and the ball
goes under both feet and you catch
if you know what i'm talking about not
like the under the one just i'm so glad
there wasn't cameras back then for video
on me just do all the stupid [ __ ]
constantly
all day just
i've been doing four hours on the same
black top just seriously
in the basement even like i'd be down
there in the basement i'd be shoveling
off the court
constantly
the day after i broke my collarbone i
was on the court in a sling
yes
this [ __ ] i rebranded the movie
re-broke my collarbone three times
from the in the same summer because i
wouldn't [ __ ] stop
playing
yeah
i tell you about when i broke my
collarbone
we were playing [ __ ] football or
something goofy broke my [ __ ]
collarbone you've known him that long
yeah wow well i mean this is all i was
like this is uh
seventh sixth or seventh grade
so that's right around the time i met
him yeah he had just kind of moved in we
started becoming best friends and [ __ ]
but he was way bigger than me because he
was like three years older than me and
he was super athletic you're shredded
you could [ __ ] dunk for real
white boy just shredded
and he played football i didn't really
play i played street football
but we did it was like hike and he like
picked me up
just kind of tossed me back and i landed
on my back and when i landed it
snapped my goofy kid is ripped yeah
that makes him a little less goofy to me
oh damn yeah
beat someone's ass that's not a goof
that's not a goofy trait
it was just natural like he was shredded
his brother was [ __ ] six seven power
dunking on fools super athletic
yes his big brother towered and ran [ __ ]
over all of us damn yeah
yeah his big brother was ripping rims
off the court he'd multiple time ripped
the [ __ ] backboard off
goofy too
yeah
yo shout out to a goof troop over there
yeah but anyway he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
for this one cause he broke my
collarbone so now we're in the middle of
the game i have a broke collarbone
that's damn near protruding out of my
skin
and he's like no no this happens to me
all the time you just pop it back in
and he like i'm like nah it's not
popping back in it's it's broke
so then i like got my
i had my basketball in my backpack i
used to ride with it like that i went to
go put the backpack on i felt it break a
little bit more
[ __ ] i've still got like adrenaline
going i get my bike and now i got like a
mile to go back to the house with the
broken [ __ ] um
collarbone you have told me that before
and then i got
attacked by a [ __ ] dalmatian
damn near right away i i leave the i
leave where we're playing football i'm
going up this big ass hill
this [ __ ] crazy ass dalmatian starts
you never hear that aggressively you're
[ __ ] barking at me yeah i don't know
super random i got a broken collarbone
my bag my bike
just trying to i got a mile i had to get
home and some woman came out of nowhere
and just [ __ ] like i don't know what
she got handled the dog ripped the dog
away i walked home and i was like i'm
good i'm not going to the hospital and
then immediately
into the [ __ ] hospital
and then i had to wear the [ __ ] the
butterfly thing but the next day i was
out there shooting one-handed
and
i i kept even i re-broke it twice in a
dream while i was sleeping
where things would happen in the dream
that would cause me to
i had a dream where i went to
goofy's older brother i had a dream i
went to slap him up but i really did it
in real life and
no
no
yeah it happened twice like that
that's
i would have tied my it was horrible
yeah it was just in it i mean i think
it's probably still [ __ ] up
you're serious yeah i was going up a
ladder too
hitting on the bottom rung of the ladder
all while i'm in a sling just
yeah
couldn't stop me though
what the [ __ ] did i say to this are you
[ __ ] kidding me this will broke his
[ __ ] in a dream
yeah we broke it
all right he broke a healing broken bone
that's so disgusting
yo how do we get on these crazy topics
i just realized i haven't eaten today i
just feel like that
[Music]
ah all right here we go
college
right
we've talked about
i mean i have
endless stories about college but how
long were you in college five [ __ ]
hours ten semesters
okay
live in that mom's house though my me
were you where where are you living i i
moved out like the day i graduated so
you're living in an apartment going to
college yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah and i moved out park avenue what up
we're parking out right behind uh yemen
donuts and the gym
yeah i moved out um
with jeebus
but before that i lived with my friend
six five named steve
but he's six [ __ ] five the guy from
the ghost story
and i was like say what's up steve [ __ ]
you steve that guy i moved out with him
and his parents and they had a house and
i rented a room did not last long it's
too hard to differentiate like yo i just
bought hella groceries and we all ate
our each other [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i can't buy groceries like i'm not gonna
i'm at work in school yes it doesn't
work when it's like
community stuff it doesn't work and plus
they're a whole family and i'm the one
that's not a fan it just didn't work you
know i mean they're cool it will never
work out yeah they were [ __ ] hella
tight it was fun no matter how cool it's
not going to be cool just didn't work
but um
yeah then i moved into the apartment i
lived my grandpa right after high school
too actually
i moved out the summer
after i graduated after the summer i
moved out not i shouldn't have said the
damned i graduated i live in my grandpa
tom
and um
[ __ ] completely forever i was going with
this have i told you okay five years of
college five years of college because i
would go for a little bit you guys heard
the story i'd go for a little a couple
months and stop well i'll go back next
semester and i go for two three [ __ ]
months and stop like i'm over it
i missed a day and now i don't know i
just algebra two [ __ ] you it's all only
class i have left [ __ ] algebra
um
so [ __ ] pointless i [ __ ] hate it
have i told you the story okay i tell
you the story about
me and my friend ryan from story times
when we went to college we signed up for
the same class about the weed smelling
and the teacher have i told you about
that no i feel like i have though i mean
so many stories you might have you might
i don't know about the podcast audience
about for the podcast if i told you the
story on the podcast where
uh you know what in case i did i'll
leave it out but i'm gonna tell you this
one quick little thing
i tell you when i signed up for the
wrong class and my teacher was asking me
about it did i talk about that on the
podcast i know about that from someone
you know i'm just gonna not i don't want
to repeat myself so i'm just gonna leave
it at it i don't know i wasn't on the
podcast i don't think
i'm trying to keep it college oriented
go ahead
just i'll do it real quick one time
i was late for a round up and i did not
get my
english class yet so i just picked
whatever class my friend ryan had
because there was an opening
i said [ __ ] it and first day of school
i'm sitting there
and i'm like huh
like two foreign kids in a row
weird
i'm sitting there with a bunch of kids
in my age group that are born in america
and speak english
and you'll get why i say that in a
second
like huh
a couple other asian exchange students
weird why are they coming into our
english class shouldn't they like
start off with the english second
language classes
teacher comes in he writes on the board
remedial english go why are you [ __ ]
kidding me
i'm in remedial oh they're foreign kids
they're in the this is the lowest oh
[ __ ]
then i wrote my first essay mr tabor
shout out to mr tabor i wrote my first
essay and he knew i was he already knew
i was high
and um he asked me to wait after class
this is like a month into school he
asked me to wait after class and i go oh
[ __ ] is it because i smell so bad
[ __ ] dude i know you shouldn't have
smoked those balls today oh okay i smoke
in my car and walk right into classes
and he goes hey man
let me ask you something
oh
yeah what's up
and he goes
why the hell are you in my classroom
what do you mean goes why are you in my
class why did you pick my class i go
all right this is what happened and i
told him what happened like i was
rushing and ryan was like there's a spot
open in this class take that [ __ ] and he
goes oh so you were [ __ ] high
nah man i was just picking my class he
goes was it one of the bong days was it
one of those days is that why you picked
my class and he was [ __ ] with me oh
no man i just
i [ __ ] up and i'm over here just like
[ __ ] i'm high
and and he goes
you can't be in my class man like
i'm reading your essay and i'd give you
an a in my regular class i can't have
you in this classroom and i go but i
don't have another class and he goes
this doesn't count towards your degree
oh [ __ ]
well i need the credits man so i guess
i'm staying and i stayed
and i passed that class with an a
because i speak english
it's like an english second language
class and i were thinking ryan why the
[ __ ] are you in this class you speak
english too [ __ ]
we both talk to each other it's because
he never does his work he never does
anything they ranked him low that's
really what it is but i remember
when all the foreign exchange students
come in like why am i here
i must have [ __ ] damn these kids must be
bomb in english something
because you can tell they're being a
second language because they're always
the kids with the huge ass backpacks and
merced if you have a big ass backpack
you're trying
nobody comes to the backpack it's a
bunch of kids in [ __ ] black air
forces
plain black shirts anchor blue jeans and
a binder or
just a notebook and a pen in their ear
and about to have two more kids i saw a
meme the other day that said all the
[ __ ] that used to just carry a
folder around high school in jail now
that's
150 percent true
it's the truest [ __ ] that was me 40 of
the time i just [ __ ] this backpack i'm
just carrying my binder i'll just carry
this and go someone's got a pencil
that's cool i don't care my pencil [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
i i was a piece of [ __ ] sometimes i felt
that not having a pencil is like
showing up to work
drunk
that's good you know like yo you can't
you can't do that bro they're going to
get paid you're not going to get in
trouble trouble but you're going to get
yelled at
it's the same thing like are you kind of
[ __ ] up yeah yeah i mean last night i
was drinking i just feel yeah cause you
stink you don't have a pencil sir what
did you think we're gonna do today yeah
have you ever gotten through class
without a pen or pencil and never had to
use one
i don't know
one [ __ ] day every period of class i
didn't need one and i was thinking wow
the one day i bring a pencil
and everything holy [ __ ] i have one
today yo why don't we talk about this oh
okay anyway
he just laughed at me and goes bro you
can't be in my class this is for [ __ ]
kids that don't speak english and
everything no but there's like four
gangster kids in here oh they're just
[ __ ] stupid
gotcha there's a great there's a couple
dumb [ __ ] in here that
oh what's up fool like yo man you should
just pay attention in class
[ __ ] wrong with you in remedial
english
um
anyway i'm i'm just kidding guys if
you're in remedial english
it's just you're not good at english
it's all right what the [ __ ] sorry for
making fun of it people out there in
remedial english watching this right now
maybe that's why because you're watching
podcasts during the class man
hey i'm just going to keep going back
and forth and talking mad [ __ ] here we
go
um i have you know what speaking of
chappelle's show i'll tell this story
marty have i ever told you about the
story about the two motorcycles at the
college i found
no i remember that one you sure that you
found two motorcycles
like brand new rice like uh crotch
rockets like dope ones you're talking
about
speaking of chappelle show
ready go
here's one more story and then we'll get
out of here we're on hour 26 we did a
good [ __ ] job today oh yeah we're
keeping it tight get it right get it hey
all right you ready
here we go
hey what's up guys welcome to our mid
roll ad read and this episode is
sponsored by manscaped this is the skin
safe technology these are ceramic and
replaceable blades this is the ultimate
male grooming kit we all know that we
have said it before if you want to have
a nasty ass
dick area don't buy manscaped but if you
give a [ __ ] and you want to bang a human
soon use manscaped if you want to check
it out go to www.manscape
forward slash yola and that is 20 off
plus free shipping and for everyone out
there that hasn't seen manscaped in a
while the lawnmower the 3.0 it was great
it's super awesome but the 4.0 just came
out guys it's skin safe like i said
ceramic blades wireless technology has a
light on the [ __ ] and it is
waterproof you have no excuse if you're
still nasty owning this [ __ ]
that you're doomed and quote from
manscape our technological masterpiece
it's called the weed whacker it's a nose
hair trimmer i didn't think i would you
know as a kid when you always see old
men with hair coming out their nose and
their ear like damn how the [ __ ] does
that happen just grow old and be alive
and it'll happen i [ __ ] promise you
i'm seeing it my homies are talking
about it's like yo are we getting older
that we have to worry about nose hair it
also comes with ball deodorant and ball
toner i'm not kidding at all but just
check it the [ __ ] out if you think
that's hilarious like i did go check out
manscaped right now
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off plus free shipping once
again guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
so
i'm at merced college right by where the
baseball field leads to
for everyone for reference if you go to
that school or you've been
i'm in the back by the field coming from
the baseball diamonds
i'm well i park my car
right behind the pool area i'm walking
around the corner and i go
wow holy [ __ ] those are badass there's
two brand new motorcycles
like
bright colors or orange green think of
like neon colors i just remember looking
at them like [ __ ] those are sick
and i don't care about motorcycles but
they caught my eye i'm with jeebus
all right
we're walking this is like a five
o'clock class he had a 5 30 class or
some [ __ ] so it's toward night time it's
not like there's a bunch of people there
anymore it's community college
and
i'm walking i see the bikes and i go
damn those are [ __ ] tight and they
both have dealer plates the little
plates on still like where the person
bought them from
so i'm like damn that full just got
those that sick
i turn the corner with the corners
eight feet away you turn the corner and
there's like a huge
path that leads to a bunch of classrooms
and it goes to the big buildings
i turn the corner and right when i turn
the corner i'm just happen to look down
and there's two sets of keys
marty
whoever had the bike
dropped both sets of keys 30 feet away
did you see what i'm saying yeah and i
went
oh it's a bait car situation going on i
underst i get it now and i thought are
they doing bait car in merced
because this is blatant mm-hmm this is
more you gotta take it take it so i can
shoot you in the [ __ ] chest that's
what it felt like
jesus christ so i see the keys and i'm
like wait
this can't be real and i pick him up so
no tweaker it's mur it is merced i pick
him up
and i'm like i gotta give this to the
[ __ ] people at the at the front desk
oh my god
we're scared of the [ __ ] man
i picked him up i picked him up and held
him like this just in case they were
looking at me so they're like oh this
guy's just returning him but i held him
like this just so it wasn't like i'm
sneaking and jesus is looking at him
he's like
bro you gotta be in class like i know so
we gotta hurry
jesus walk with me i walk to the first
little building on the right
and the office is closed so i have to
walk across the entire campus
to go to the front building and find a
desk person that i can leave the keys
tell them where i found the keys and the
bikes because someone's going to be
looking for those keys
and i couldn't bring in myself to go
[ __ ] they'll find them because like yo
you just got em they just got to class
they're gonna come out in the middle of
the night and go no i gotta leave my
bikes overnight like that's a bummer so
i was thinking i gotta get these keys to
somebody i go to the next office there's
nobody [ __ ] there and i find some
random office it was and it turned out
to be like student help or some [ __ ]
help desk
then i gave her the keys i go hey i
explained everything to her
and i and we leave and i tell jesus yo
we gotta go leave a note on the bikes
letting him know like yo you're going to
the [ __ ] something building your keys
right
i was just trying to be cool right
and then as we're walking i'm like jeez
i'm going to write a stupid dope i was
like could you imagine if i left an
ignorant ass note
but like being a good samaritan in
ignorant form
you'll get what i mean i could imagine i
keep what i mean so i was like you know
what watch this
and i left i le i wrote a note rolled it
up and put it right in the ignition
where the keys at so they would see it
you know what i mean so they know to
open that what the [ __ ]
speaking of chappelle show
jeebs is there jesus is with me
do you remember when they did the birth
of crack
and the gangs corn rolla they did that
skit where most death played the other
[ __ ] gangster and they stomped him
out and killed him
remember that skit
remember he writes the [ __ ] note from
prison how to cook crack get uh bakings
i wrote just like that
left joe keys with the [ __ ] at the
front
if you go down at the help desk and i
spelled [ __ ] all [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
letters did my handwriting's dog [ __ ]
but i spelled [ __ ] [ __ ] up left your
keys with the [ __ ] at the desk
all this stupid [ __ ] all this dumb stuff
jeebus is dying laughing i'm like bro
could you imagine though when they see
and go
this ignorant [ __ ] is a good
person and at the end
if you're chappelle fan spell show fan
at the end i put p s
like three lines
and then i left i went to classroom
i love that i got out and the [ __ ]
bikes are gone wow somebody went through
the whole scenario of having to read and
decipher this and go
oh bro
i did that in college 10 years ago and i
am still proud as [ __ ]
of how funny it was it must have been
and the worst thing that could have
happened they went uh net arm get my
keys [ __ ] this
that's what i hope didn't happen yeah
but i hope someone went and fell to the
ground dying loud because they know the
[ __ ] what it's from
because if i got that
i'd have to find the person and hang out
with him mm-hmm
yeah this fool's got to be hilarious
there's no way they're not
that's still gonna go the extra mile on
something like that to be funny
for you i had just for me and geez i'm
like yo
wouldn't it be funny he goes are you
gonna do you [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna do it
the [ __ ] i spell [ __ ] all [ __ ] up
it was
one of my prouder moments bro nice but
that happened in college i didn't
accomplish anything more than that
that was my biggest accomplishment of
college for sure i did nothing more
um
yep oh you found you put something from
college to good use here today
pr pr
it was oh i gotta put that on the cell
board yeah on the soundboard every time
something's sick happens
if you haven't seen it go watch the
chappelle show it's the one with most
death it's the woman to talk about how
to cook crack
it is [ __ ] hysterical they steal his
dead body and take pictures with his
dead body yo
then he's a shoe salesman 20 years later
yeah we started it in this very spot now
i work here at a shoe sale or you know
i'm sorry i'll leave it at that guys
this has been a very ranty podcast but
this is the college podcast i like the
centralized theme it was cool i i like
this was the first time we did that
where you just said you
had some sort of a direction of like
just a theme yeah but you think of
something but
i like your uh
disgusting kids moment
where marcellus wallace was gonna eat
you
how
weird and odd
yeah nah he was cool he was yeah nah he
was cool
[ __ ] me up if you wanted to
i mean imagine
a man i did
the whole time i'm with this girl she's
doing all this crazy ass [ __ ] i'm just
like this fool is like in the next room
already got to be suspecting the 15 year
old boy in his house
jesus christ [ __ ] white kid with blue
eyes came over i don't know he's dunking
and rapping i gotta wait i gotta keep an
eye on i like to be on stealth mode
around parents back then
that was not the case
yo real quick i'm just gonna tell this
small slight story
it has nothing to do with college just
real quick for you out here you talking
about that being stealth mode my sister
she's gay right i told you that my
sister's gay and in high school she was
dating this chick
and this chick was super [ __ ] pretty
and all the dudes in my school wanted to
bang her and then she came out and was
dating my sister out of nowhere
and it was really funny because i was
like damn my sister pulled up one of the
hotter chicks this was cool good [ __ ] i
thought it was funny like
good
anyway
her parents hate my sister
hate her with a passion because they
find they don't want her their daughter
to be gay
they don't and they hate my [ __ ]
sister for it
hates my sister they've been in multiple
crazy arguments and i'm gonna run away
type
lesbian high school drama
you know you've seen the movies like
we're running away together that's
that's exactly how it's like
i mean it's with any kid but two chicks
ready go
i look like a baby
and
imagine me at 15
a child
right i look like i was an infant still
this chick her [ __ ] parents like i
said hate my sister my sister never
asked me for anything
and she goes hey i need a favor and i'm
like what [ __ ] what happened she's a
dick you guys know that she was a dick
to me and she's asking me for a favor
all right what
she goes
can you pretend to be dating veronica
and go pick her up in a car i give you
so we can go out
and you pretend to be the new kid that's
trying to date her daughter and you go
meet her parents and go what the [ __ ]
did you just say to me [ __ ] yeah i'll
do that [ __ ]
and i just as
you know what that's going to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] funny that's going to be
win or lose that's a funny situation
so i did it and i remember everything
about it i have no license i have no car
i pull up in this car with my sister
laying in the backseat with a blanket
over here
jesus christ like some ferris bueller
and i go like hey
i'll be right back
[ __ ] [ __ ] i get out of the car i
go in and i meet her mom and dad at the
door mexicans mexican family and but
they're like they're cool they start
talking in spanish nope no they just go
oh her mom just looks at me and goes
oh my god
like he's okay he's normal looking
right that's what she thought like oh my
gosh you're dating guys now oh my
[ __ ] god who is it now their mom was
just
she seemed cool like she could be cool
even my mom wanted to be her ass
she was like your daughter's the reason
my daughter's guy all this bullsh and
it was a long yeah drama thing anyway
i walk in i walk into the people's house
and now i am obligated to finish this
out and see what happens
her girlfriend's right there looking at
me like
bro you're really doing this [ __ ]
meet the dad meet the mom she's like oh
my god oh oh i love your smile oh
good job she's talking to her daughter
like oh i'm so what are you guys going
to watch i'm like oh we're going to a
movie and we'll probably go to la cienda
or something it's a mexican restaurant
everybody goes to it's like yeah we're
going to go see a movie i don't know
what movie yet but we're going to meet
two more friends blah blah
the dad goes oh that's great man let me
see your license
i had to think of my feet
this is where this is why i was like you
know what
i was born to be an actor i guess
because i pulled it out of my ass i went
oh my wallet's actually in the car um
let me go right now and get it you wanna
be up and he goes up i'm just messing
with you man it's cool but the fact that
we all go get he was like okay you're
good
but i was like what am i gonna go get
yeah if i go outside what am i to go get
and bring back off
so he was like oh i'm just messing with
him and he's like you guys can be back
by 10 and go yeah 100 i'll be right back
here drop her off
and then i was like let's go and i was
weird i'm like oh hi i'm like oh i
touched you you're my sister's
girlfriend this is disgusting to me
right now
it's weird it's like you're my sister
it's odd
i'm like oh hi and then we walk to the
car open the door we get it i hit the
corner i'm like and i'm right when i hit
the corner i go you [ __ ] [ __ ] i
can't believe i did that she gets up oh
my god it worked and then i they dropped
me back off and i smoked some weed and
they went and did whatever the [ __ ] they
did
that's it i didn't have to drop her off
because her parents go to bed early for
work or whatever so she just made sure
she was home at 10. damn well that was a
dream move on your part i was i i wanted
to see it like can i pull this off and
let me do that that is a [ __ ] super
bad style scenario it was good though
man it was good it was on some ferris
bueller [ __ ] i don't know why i said yes
honestly
i mean i mean i don't know why looking
back like dude why did you do that
it's not she gave me some money though
that's what i'm just gonna say yeah
so here i go
yeah all right i'm gonna go smoke weed
now i'll be this bitch's boyfriend for
yeah we're we're married we're married
right okay
i just thought it was very very funny
and then um
they found out i think a couple weeks
later because her mom caught my sister
with her again
and then they found out uh my name is
thomas oh what's your last name i might
know your parents garcia
and he goes you're
causing this man um no my family's like
from modesto area
it's live damn bam i just try to like oh
no they're all from modesto oh yeah i
only know merced area i go yeah i know
my grandma's here my mom lives here i
was just saying things that were true
that i could also double that i wouldn't
[ __ ] up on
i just had to remember hey maybe it was
from modesto but yeah my grandma oh well
she works with
yeah you might know myself i was just
saying words
and
one thing she did say
um she kind of mentioned my sister but
not mentioned like well yeah i'm just
glad you know she's not here or she says
i'm glad she's not she's not here or
something like that i'm like damn this
lady's a [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] me too i know jesus
christ yeah i know she punches me
sometimes
um
but yeah dude uh
that that was i don't know why i
remember that i remembered it because
you you said something i thought
oh yeah
i remember this one time i did this for
sure like
i forgot i've never even done story time
on that i should do that that was
[ __ ] hilarious to me
pulled it off though man they had no
[ __ ] idea but they did find out later
that i was strange's brother
[Music]
because they found out everything that
was her little brother they felt played
i never had to see them again i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm trying to picture myself as the dad
in that scenario oh my god
i was all buffing on the football team
still like i was all like hi sir like oh
yeah you go to merchant high like yeah
i'm in the 11th grade and i was a
[ __ ] freshman
oh i was 14 when i did this
no i just turned 15. i just i was a
freshman
but yeah dude i got away with the [ __ ]
jesus christ yeah they felt mad played
i think her my sister
somebody tried to stab somebody i can't
remember what happened but there was
like a police some [ __ ] happened her mom
my sister got into a fight or something
someone tried to get let me try stack
camera which way who tried to stab but
from past experience i can guarantee my
sister had a knife
and maybe not the moving end yeah
just from things i've experienced
so uh
college
pretending
i've done a lot of things like that yeah
yeah yeah anytime you get an opportunity
to go jump into a bit and show it i
didn't think that was what it was but
yeah that's really what it was i've uh
pretended to be my friend's dad's a lot
on the phone
it's only worked a few times
it's a lot different stepping into a
man's house [ __ ]
that's something i felt trapped yeah
then i thought like
i'm gonna rip this whole mustache off if
he gets crazy with me a little
[ __ ] cause imagine wait
they pieced some [ __ ] together but isn't
that your girlfriend's mom doesn't she
is that her name yep
yep
i changed my mom's name though mm-hmm
i think i said like becky i said it a b
betty or becky or some [ __ ] i said
garcia garcia is so common
[ __ ] i'm feeling rage for this
wall that's a that's
great
the dad marty came out like you know
what thomas i think i might fight him
are you for him
it wasn't my fault i wasn't trying to
bang your daughter literally wasn't
trying to get your daughter nothing like
that
your sister was a [ __ ] mastermind
she was a wild [ __ ]
for sure
that girl snuck over our house
every [ __ ] night
her parents are bad parents
do your kick is sneak out every single
[ __ ] day if she wants
lock her window from the outside man
something something take a you know what
put some beads put some beads on the
outside of her window or something so
she has to make
this is some simple tactics that you
could take you keep a baby in a crib
[ __ ] yeah keep this girl that's
going to see licenses and [ __ ] yeah
you're serious get some cameras going or
something you got insurance
like
yeah
it was man i'm just about to put 35
[ __ ] cameras on my house i'm
not going through this type of [ __ ] i
got my eyes well i can tell you
everything i'm so sorry all of marty's
children
you guys are never getting away with
[ __ ] i have sold drugs under my mom's
nose i have snuck people in and out of
houses
i've done everything you can possibly
think of
crazy and i've gotten away with all that
i'm just good with persuading and making
people think that i was yeah no this is
garcia
it's because i think it's once you
believe that it's real it comes off so
genuine mm-hmm so if you believe like i
think that's how people do acting [ __ ]
like getting together acting they get
into character and [ __ ] yeah because i
just did it because i knew like if i get
caught this fool might fight me
and i'm about to beat her i'm about to
beat her parents up
i'm getting out of this house i think
i'm thinking like all scenarios if i got
caught
but that was it dude i have a
that's pretty much it 145 marty all
right good job good job 145 for everyone
driving
this episode today was super blurry for
me
it felt like all one big ever since
freeway rick ross life has been just so
fast without chaoting and [ __ ] and like
we filmed him over a week and a half ago
we always feel the same time every week
we're five days late to our own filming
right now it's different it's different
it's cool though it is cool next week we
have boo johnson coming hell yeah can we
talk about who we have coming up or no
should we wait let's definitely wait
because then it's going to be the season
2 premiere no i'm saying that's what i
was going to say yeah
stop right there okay so a requested
person that's a very requested person
season two with yeah we're gonna open up
season two with them it's gonna be good
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome the dude
yeah i feel way better about it our our
consultant came through and was like
yeah that sounds pretty perfect yeah
dude our new set is coming our new set's
coming it's gonna look the same except
i'll be on a flat wall instead of the
corner
that's it less sweat less everything
yeah less and just cleaner less echo
yeah none of that
nothing like that
yeah
what are you about to do today
edit this [ __ ] podcast all right i'm
about to go edit the i smoked an ounce
in the sitting yesterday
about two days ago it was before two
years yeah two days ago i smoked and it
for a video and it
[ __ ] my chest up because i was smoking
so much so fast because my friends
i started filming at 9 30 because i know
i have to get it cut off at four because
one of my best homies is his daughter's
his first child's first birthday
and he went all out got a carnival for
this little baby
i can't be late because he's gonna talk
[ __ ] like you're late it's her first
birthday [ __ ]
not for real but that's our
dynamic whatever
and i'm like i can't give nothing to say
so i'm sitting here going
it's 245
[Music]
i was trying to [ __ ] power smokey's
joints so fast i smoked six at once
i held six joints at once during the
video just smoking as fast as i could
and looking at the time like
i've never rushed videos but i gotta
rush this [ __ ] video
to go to a one-year-old's birthday party
and i got there i made it but i was an
hour late which is fine but i made it
yeah it was cool but that's meaningful
to a dad yeah so i'm gonna uh edit that
today
and you're gonna edit this today how odd
yeah that's how it goes no i'm saying
how i wish we could like have another
person filming bts so the bts of that
talking is gonna go back to you and
you're editing and we just put that in
the end of the podcast yeah and then we
just get some random dude in his room to
go and take a video so everybody just
what the [ __ ]
that'd be funny
that's inception yeah yeah exactly i
love that i want to start i'm going to
start putting out more see the [ __ ] up
part about it is i have this amazing
office right next to my new house oh i
heard and i can't find the [ __ ] keys
okay smaller [ __ ] he's been moving and
he packed his own working in a goddamn
construction zone
because i can't find the keys to my
beautiful office right now it'll dig
through my storage unit
but this next week there's gonna be a
lot more background track meanwhile i'm
doing torp all my clients are on the
road i'm doing tour posters for all
these comedians huge tour posters
dopeziola dopes adventures videos and
[ __ ]
uh i don't spend a lot one thing marty
doesn't know exists
locksmiths
hmm yeah already could just get a
locksmith to come make a key for the
office yeah well i just had keys made
that's the problem and then they're gone
though bro you have to get new keys
they're they're in my storage unit you
pack this own office keys in the storage
unit that is the most frustrating thing
i could probably think of because i had
to rip apart
all of our [ __ ] in
stacked up like jenga blocks in our
garage right now to determine that there
must be in the storage unit
yeah so
i feel frustrated for you doing all that
[ __ ] i wanted to i've been getting
hundreds of [ __ ] messages people
asking me where to listen to my old
music oh yes please drop that
where's the link i've been i've been
just putting a lot of hundreds of
comments up i wanted to post up some
mixtapes before this episode but it's
probably going to take me another week
or so but
all my mixtapes are on datpiff i don't
think people probably use that anymore
that should probably die can you post it
on youtube though um yeah so i'm gonna
like if you go on spotify there is a
couple songs under drastic graphics that
i put up i posted just because i wanted
to get the drastic trying to get uh yeah
verifying on instagram and [ __ ] so
but i'm gonna post up all my mixtapes
though so people don't want to go back
and listen to that [ __ ] can and might as
well like i have probably four or five
mixtapes
six or seven if i really you do me a
favor
at the end of this episode
instead of our outro since you own the
music
you should put on that noriega [ __ ] um
just the start of it
[ __ ] buffalo oh bro
you should put that on as soon as it
goes all right i have a dope and i take
it off
in our outro and it's just that full
talking introducing your mixtape
sick you made me remember that that was
sick yeah i had a cool component oriego
host
probably don't know the [ __ ] that is
anymore yes they do people do know nori
for sure from drink champs and all that
[ __ ] but capone and noriega capone and
we might be having we can say we might
be having [ __ ] metal world peace run
our test on the [ __ ] show at some
point we're trying to get which is a big
connection
and uh which is random but
ties into what we're talking about i
might post it he he hosted my first
mixtape and the [ __ ] was so epic i let
thomas hear it and he's like what the
[ __ ] and then marty explained that he
hadn't heard it yet told me the whole
story says he gets in the car with all
his homies puts in the mixtape because
he's like okay my mixtape's done we went
to pick it up in brooklyn yeah
i had spent like i went and took out i
was like 18. took out five thousand
dollar loan which was the more money
than i had ever had before money ordered
it directly to these fools give me my 5
000 mixtapes all this [ __ ] they produced
the whole thing the artwork
that they got capone to host it they did
it all we went down there picked up
barely fit in the [ __ ] cart all the
inserts boxes of blank disks boxes of
cds
and then but i hadn't heard it yet so we
popped it in and i was like oh [ __ ] they
really went in on it because he hosted
it like back in the day you'd get yeah
he hosted my mixtape he got on there and
said something for 30 seconds no
the first two minutes
he did a whole inch he did every song
like he they told me he went in there
with a bottle and showed them listen to
it and he was just talking in between
tracks talking [ __ ] like he did an
interlude he did an outro he did way
more than he had to i really appreciated
that [ __ ] because he was he is a legend
and was even back then war report all
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] legendary to me so
it reminded me that you know i want to
put that back out there this shit's
funny but that situation i said is part
of next another part of our movie you
pop in your mixtape and this video
starts introducing your [ __ ] exactly i
listen to this [ __ ] i'm certified by me
like oh [ __ ] i got hyped
and this is [ __ ] 12 years later and
[ __ ] driving my house yeah bro please
just end it let's end it
our logo popping up on our end screens
just let it trail off all right dude you
own the music yeah yeah your music
you're good yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah
well
i'll keep you guys updated on that
hopefully by next episode the music
you're gonna spotify or something
spotify if not can you just throw them
up like with this picture on your in
youtube i could
you have a stoic youtube that yeah i
have that old one
yeah because the drastic graphics page
is like an artist page
but
i didn't know like youtube and youtube
music are completely separate if you
want to post the youtube music you got
to post the same way you post a spotify
and apple and all that other [ __ ] it's
not linked to your regular youtube
account so yeah i could go back and
upload a [ __ ] thousand songs to
youtube but that's probably not the best
way to go i'll probably just put it out
you know
like i'd rather post it in a way that's
meaningful i'd like to grow my youtube
channel that'd be cool but it's really
more about just people that want to
listen yeah because people have been
asking so [ __ ] much man yeah i must
did a couple hundred comments just your
name and it's cool because if you go
from like 2005 2009
like if i were to i was thinking i might
go live one time and just kind of break
it down what was going on because it's
all about the [ __ ] we've been talking
about you can really hear your timeline
of you all your [ __ ] is so wild
it's crazy like this oh that was the
time during this like oh that two years
so much [ __ ] was going on
yeah it is i i gotta i haven't even
really listened i gotta go back and
really like since we've been talking
about it i have and i started thinking
like yeah i might as well put it out
there
do it yeah so so that's where you can
find his music guys be stay tuned follow
marty on instagram it's drastic graphics
drastic underscore graphics follow him
follow our a podcast dope as usual
podcast that's on instagram also
that's why you stay updated when he
drops something like well there's my
music there it is because we have two to
three guests coming in the row so we're
not going to be like by the way yeah
brought our test
go follow marty's music is
i mean we could
that'd be pretty mean
but [ __ ] hilarious yeah yeah um okay
okay okay two it's a minute hour 54. we
did okay we did a good job
a little under two hours thank you guys
so much for watching thank you for
hanging out with us if you're in the car
this was definitely a high-ass episode i
feel it i feel like
i should have slept
um
but yeah that was it episode 33 this
one's gonna be called college or
something i don't know trying to think
more
topic-oriented episodes we go to war
with youtube over every [ __ ] change
up our title so much because they're
like oh this is inappropriate
[ __ ] do i have to be like a rapper or
something for you guys to be like no
it's fine now because since you're not a
weed guy like what is it man
simple i got a lot of people on this
channel telling me they're getting uh no
notifications also
it's okay thank you guys for watching
we're about to hit 125k which is [ __ ]
cool yeah and if you really want to be
down go to doubleziola.com sign up to
the website
because we're going to start using that
more yeah and it's freaking free it's
free leave comments likes comments likes
you can watch all of our videos same
thing as the same platform just on our
website dopajol.com just click podcast
and that goes to every single thing
about the podcast click push trees all
of our clothes adventures of viola all
my family friendly channel that i do
it's got 200 like eight 200 something
thousand followers and i don't even use
that [ __ ] really i need to utilize that
but it's not weed i can't be explicit
myself
so it's like i feel like i'm just
it's hard it's hard to think of ideas
that go let's go to the store
[Music]
oh man i'm like that's what youtubers do
oh [ __ ] i don't want to be a youtuber
uh oh smoke a zip and go to one year old
birthday let's [ __ ] get it
that sounds fun
but yeah okay i'm [ __ ] high i'm about
to go eat some food edit this
[ __ ] video you're about to edit
this video so when you're editing marty
right here
this part when you're editing it's going
to be really funny when you're editing
it
because it's going to be like so it's
like looking at a mirror inside of a
mirror
i love it all right guys thank you so
much marty appreciate you man
thank you for being here
guys thank you for being here if you're
in the car please be safe we keep
getting the messages people getting in
accidents please be careful laugh with
your eyes open
laugh with your eyes open your hands on
the [ __ ] wheel all right i've gotten
about seven people saying they got in
car accidents i know it's not your fault
i'm just saying please be careful i'm
just talking [ __ ] thank you guys for
watching go to dopaziola.com if you want
to see everything we do
check it out guys if like we said the
best way to support the podcast is tell
a friend tell a friend send them a link
by check the [ __ ] out that's the best
thing you could ever do
it's 40 of our fans are from that
people somebody sent me a link and i
just been watching ever since like yes
[ __ ] yeah so thank you guys so much for
suggesting it to your homies i got a
couple people telling me now their moms
watch it with them every monday which is
[ __ ] awesome yes i love that i've
seen a couple people watch it like it's
[ __ ] late night show
and it's very cool with their whole face
with their whole families bro it's
[ __ ] crazy
i love it
so guys thank you so much for watching
thank you for supporting thank you for
everything this has been episode 33 of
the dope as usual podcast from marty and
i have a dopest day
i'm high
[ __ ] high dude
it's the no food thing i think
oh
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]